[Music]
you laugh
you lose got to do full of what i do
season one
episode one pilot prequel
beta version version alpha 1.1
let's freaking do this let's just jump
into it damn so the rules is simple you
laugh
you lose smash like right now to accept
this challenge
and smash like if you are watching this
video right now
let's freaking do this i am
excited what do you got what is that
ma put the dogs away there's something
in the backyard
what is it mom put those dogs away
there's something in the backyard person
what is that it's a cat oh my god
he's back
call of
no stupid ugly cat
is that real is that like makeup it's
wearing makeup
wilfred wilfred warrior
oh my god oh
oh my god
[Music]
wilfred well fred
come on it doesn't count if it's wilfred
i didn't know it was wilfred
health back please namaste that's
freaking oh my god
first you get your human you wrap up
your human
stuff if you don't okay one say one two
three go what did you go
and this is how to package here
to kill your sister everyone let's
freaking do this what did you go
and this is how to package her
okay looks like i'm still in the game
boys
oh god
that is not funny peter please
unsubscribe right now i don't need your
judgment here
that was funny my dude just yo to gator
you have a yield a gator you haven't
yelled at a gigantic before
hey look it's my channel i'm just gonna
say
hey man i really appreciate your content
you've gotten me through some tough
times
and i respect them
[Laughter]
i didn't know if this would be funny
just for me or if it was funny for other
people because
i i always really appreciate when fans
are
you know express their gratitude or
whatever uh
but i never know how to respond i i
don't know like
thank you that's all i can really say
but
hey man i really appreciate your content
you've gotten me through look at the guy
look at the guy
uh you can't ask for a better comedic
timing than that all right i don't think
i'm doing very good by the way what's my
health
let's check it out looks like i'm still
winning smash like if you're also
a person just a little sodium chloride
actually dude
it's that's what i said no dude you said
sodium chloride
yes it's the same as salt but you could
have just said salt
instead everyone in this town knows
you're a boy genius dude you don't need
to say overly large words
to sound more intelligent the fact of
the matter is that nobody cares how
smart you are
if anything calling simplistic objects
by their scientific name ironically
makes you seem less intelligent more
pompous
i know you're smart enough to be better
than this by the way
i think i can pull off a jimmy neutron
haircut
[Music]
gotta do that you gotta do the swirl oh
yeah
oh yeah um what age did my little um
lelox when did my tourette's start
it started when i touched it it started
when i was
[Laughter]
i think i think dave told me about her
because she had a she had a tick of
[ __ ]
i don't know if it's her but i let me
check are you planning on playing any
other games on this channel
i do play other games sometimes i'm
currently working on it with a
potato pc so i am it's given up on me a
few times when i've tried to play other
games but i do play
the forest i play bioshock i play with
my dick on a tuesday for
you and jesus [ __ ] you [ __ ] lasagna
yeah oh no
what have i done i think she mentioned
that she's okay with people laughing
about it that's why
okay beyond first interview but 500
facial animations great
come on hurry up i'll be right here
oh it's just facial animations okay
that's great hello jody
come in oh oh no
defoe please no oh god my name is nathan
nathan dawkins i thought it would be a
good idea for us to have a little chat
get to know him please
that is if it's okay with you of course
what is happening how do you make these
[Music]
you like it i wonder if they did it
beyond two souls you can have it if you
want
oh my god stop oh they have they have
okay let's check it out
i found you by the side of the road in
the middle no it's still beyond
was there an accident
did someone try to hurt you oh my god
oh oh not the dogs dpo23
please please make one what is it called
detroit detroit become human that would
be so good
i would love that no what are you doing
what do you do what are you doing
is that a thing honestly i kind of want
to hear it what is bro sound effect
3 sound like of course
of course how could i have been so
stupid
obviously officers in lancaster
pennsylvania
were asking people to be on the lookout
for a man who robbed a store
and i think yeah i think we do
we do have his description we take that
let's take his description
is he an elf okay
this is the guy there 100 people in
pennsylvania to be out on the lookout
for
he's got uh he's got a nose and some
hair
he's got a nose in the hand he was
wearing a hat
with this particular pleased it's got
kind of a
[Music]
uh that cannot be real i hope it is the
god damn
ah jeez ah jeez looks like i'm real
low ah guys ah it looks like
i'm gonna have to tap out sorry let's
play the rest of the clips without me uh
that would make it easier
all genders our country all people
where are gamers oh my god thank you
finally a man that sings beyond the wall
where are gamers
sm it makes me so sick that gamers keep
having to
face this sort of
discrimination
sorry for late reply was watching
youtube
please say no please wait no do you
watch pewdiepie
no okay okay
what the hell is your problem duckling
not okay
i'll have you killed i'll have your
whole family killed
this is not a threat it's facts
on a friend request except kalidadi is
about to pass pewdiepie and subscribers
alexa please
[Music]
okay
luigi number one
while luigi knowing this time that was
great
that was great thank you for watching
another episode of
scottada florida manon an epic episode i
will say that was pretty epic
yeah yeah let's go with that i'll see
you guys tomorrow
on the next episode of whatever is up
tomorrow i'll see you guys tomorrow
bye
[Music]
so